there are as wasteful behavior that
should be you know flushed out of our
body politic and homosexuality is one of
those wasteful behaviors
you better occupied
I have no respect for the American press
oh I don't you get out of now go home
and bake cook the Occupy movement if it
wasn't so dangerous to the American
ideal it would be comical no the tea
party doesn't have anything in common
with those people at all they should
just go to Cuba do their thing in Cuba I
think they ought to shower and shave and
you'll get a bath and come back and
behave like you know civilized human
beings Ron Paul Ralph Nader Romney
anybody who can beat Obama I'm a mitt
romney guy I feel like he can beat Obama
I think Romney's the only guy who could
beat obama at this point is there
anything besides that that you like
about Romney he's got a lot of money and
organization I'm probably more in tune
with Gingrich it's not afraid to tell
you he's made mistakes unfortunately
some of his ideas are awful we keep
praying for the second coming of Reagan
but it's not going to happen wow that
get a degree I'm out and Jeff no job
dude how about my disappoint you at all
yeah he did bailing out all the large
banks not really prosecuting anyone for
it not ending the wars increasing the
militarization of this country gianna
presidential candidate of choice for
2012 why believe that we will be able to
make much difference well how many
perpetuate a lot of the same policies
that you have I mean I believe that the
people will be able to make a change and
he will be less opposition then but why
is it a change of it's the same
president because we're gonna make our
own change yeah different competencies
to leave my president although give him
that Obama supported the bailouts isn't
he just as bad as the Republicans no
because they put that on him it is
nothing whoa it's been his dumb i
support rick santorum i have from pretty
much the beginning given that he voted
for the expansion of Medicare is he
really a fiscal conservative at all i
think during his time in Washington even
senator Santorum who I do support hadn't
got caught up a little bit in the go
along to get along supporting his
president who was pressing for the
expansion do you support Newt Gingrich
like given that gingrich got 1.6 million
from consulting with freddie and fannie
do you uh jury's still out on that one
you know i'd like to see exactly world
whether his comments where his comments
yes let's continue to to get this money
or his comments that he was paid for
that we should shut it down now they go
proud the gay Republican organization
has been booted do you feel more
comfortable without groups like that
present I don't really care I have a lot
of gay friends homosexual vice is a
moral disorder so that shouldn't be the
basis upon which somebody promotes their
ideas there are as wasteful behavior
that should be you know flushed out of
our body politic and homosexuality is
one of those wasteful behaviors do you
think of engrish presidency could help
with that
I don't know what his position is on it
do you have any problems with the fact
that he's on his third wife well um it's
better that he be with a wife there are
times in my generation where women died
earlier my Martha her husband died at
the same time two of her children died
all right fingers lives there still I
understand I understand they can become
normal human beings I've got friends or
former homosexuals and they're sometimes
it's eat that